[Music]
mission impossible fallout sees Tom
Cruise return as IMF agent Ethan Hunt
filled with nail-biting action scenes
breakneck twists and turns and one of
the best single-shot scenes ever put to
film fallout stands as one of the
greatest action movies of the air
there's a lot to unpack from the film
and some of the reveals may leave some
viewers scratching their head by the end
of the final scenes your mission should
you choose to accept it is to watch this
video in which I will cover the thumbs
plot and ending in full detail to make
sure you haven't missed anything there
will be heavy spoilers and ballout is
definitely worth your time so I highly
recommend that you come back to this
video if you're yet to see the film with
that out the way I'm definition and I
ruin the movie so you don't have to
after the capture of Solomon Lane at the
end of Mission Impossible rogue nation
the syndicate has dissolved still loyal
to Lane a shadowy organization made up
of his followers codenamed the Apostles
has risen to terrorize the world once
more they believe that a great suffering
will cause the world to seek peace and
managed to attain three nuclear bombs
during an arms deal gone wrong in which
hunt was present at due to this failing
the CIA put their best man agent Walker
played by Henry Cavill on the task to a
hunt in recapturing the bombs with
Walker Hunt travels to Paris to
impersonate the leader of the Apostles
John Locke and meet with a broker named
the White Widow when Locke is killed
hunt must take his place without a mask
and meets the white widow who is
revealed to be Max's daughter from the
first Mission Impossible film the widow
informs Hunt that in order to get the
nuclear weapons back he must capture
Solomon Lane and turn him over an arms
exchange this worries Walker who tells
his boss that he believes hunt is in
fact Locke and using the double bluff as
a cover in order to carry out the
mission hunt captures Lane and manages
to bring him to London much to the
dismay of Ilsa
- played by Rebecca Ferguson Faust has
been disavowed by mi6 but knows that
should she kill Lane that she would be
able to return home in London Walker is
tricked into revealing that he is in
fact locked by a trap set up by Ethan
however upon attempting to bring Locke
in other apostles that have infiltrated
the CIA killed director Hunley and Locke
managed to escape by threatening to
murder hunts of now ex-wife hunt and the
gang have about the plan though and have
placed a tracking device in Lane which
they managed to follow to a remote
village where hunt discovers his ex-wife
is working as a relief worker Lane
activates the nukes and hunt races
across the sky to obtain the detonator
whilst the ground troops disable the
bombs it's a fantastic finale that sees
Henry Cavill end up looking like
crossbones and it has one of the best
action scenes in the series thus far
Lane once again is captured and in the
final scenes we see that he is handed
over to the white widow this is because
the white widow was a wanted woman but
handing over the world's number one
terrorist will absolve her of her past
dealings and other families earlier in
the film she tried to arrange a deal in
which she could return Faust to the mi6
as a prisoner along with Lane but this
new deal cuts a corner and allows Faust
to carry on free once more with larks
confession already captured on camera
earlier in the film the IMF have little
to worry about in terms of going rogue
and hunts ex-wife admits that it was
selfish to carry on with their marriage
when Ethan is one of the most capable
agents when it comes to stopping the
apocalypse the film ends on a high note
and I cannot wait to see how lame plays
into future sequels and what the next
mission for the IMF will be in order to
get fully up to speed with fallout I
went back and watched the Mission
Impossible films from the original Brian
DePalma espionage thriller all the way
up to the stunts heavy modern takes
ranking the series from best to worse
for me they currently stand at Mission
Impossible to their Mission Impossible
Mission Impossible rogue nation Mission
Impossible 3 and joint first I really
don't know between Mission Impossible
Fallout and Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol perhaps if I have a bit more
time with fallout of be able to
differentiate the two but after just
leaving the cinema I think the film is
absolutely incredible so what did you
think of Mission Impossible fallout
how would you rank the franchise and do
you think the phone was worth Henry
cavils horribly CGI'd face in Justice
League comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video please like it
and subscribe to my channel I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the ending of the equalizer
too and what the main themes of the
franchise are so make sure you check
that out next thanks very much for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and this tape will self-destruct in
five seconds look I'm sorry but everyone
does that joke I'm sorry
just please subscribe please and take
care peace
[Music]
you